this show is brought to you by cso
cso
s-e-e-s-o is the new ad-free streaming
service bringing you hilarious original
series hand-picked classics weeks of
stand-up specials and more bingeable
comedy anytime anywhere see so s-e-e-s-o
and right now our listeners get a free
trial for two months
of c so you get cso for free for two
months when you use promo code joey at
checkout so go to
csoseso.com right now to sign up for two
free months
with promo code joey at checkout that's
cso.com promo code joey
this show is also brought to you by
hint water
hint water
is offering our listeners a single
variety pact shipped directly to your
door including three bottles of hints
four most popular flavors pineapple
watermelon crisp apple and blackberry
which is normally twenty four dollars
for only fifteen at drinkhit.com
church that's drink h-i-n-t dot com
church drink hint dot com slash church
show is also brought to you by helix
sleep
go to helix sleep where you could.com
where you can buy mattresses online
customized for you for hundreds of
dollars instead of thousands
go to helixsleep.com joey right now and
get fifty dollars off of your order
that's helixsleep.com joey to get 50 off
of your order helixsleep.com
joey
kick that [ __ ] mule lee it's early
monday morning
uncle joey
dean del rey
my jewish goomba lisa the church of
what's happening now [ __ ]
kick it lee
what the [ __ ] do you think you're
dealing with [ __ ]
it's a whole new week [ __ ]
strap a pair on here we go
are you [ __ ] kidding me
oh [ __ ]
you can't stop rock and roll you can't
stop dick you understand me uncle joey
the church of what's happening now early
monday morning the 24th of october my
main man dean delrissie
man that song is silver it comes out
firing oh man i thought about that jam
all day today i don't know why i was
like i'm not even a twisted [ __ ]
sister fan but when it comes to like i
walked out of the show one time you did
yeah i was young they had makeup on oh
yeah i'll tell you when i went to see
him the first time at a bar in jersey
they had makeup on wow and the guy was
what didn't tolerate none of that [ __ ] i
didn't tolerate none of that [ __ ] we
looked at each other with the chance
dragging in
call for the night on a friday night
that's it wow i i uh this band
they just called it
that's it they ended it about a month
ago
they did like three shows in jersey new
york and queens or something that's it
and uh last week i was asked to host
this uh 30-year anniversary of the best
club ever in l.a it was called the cat
house and ricky rackman ran it from uh
you know uh that mtv you know
ricky rackman what was the cat house it
was on uh there was two locations it
started on los cienega at this place and
then it moved to highland
uh at a club called probe and it was the
hottest club ever in l.a and it's like
where guns and roses play and faster
pussycat all ground zero jet boy
all these bands uh junkyard motorhead
and everybody hung there it was a
tuesday night club you had to have a one
dollar
like membership card because they
figured out if you were a membership
they could turn people away at the door
without being uh rude yeah so
they have ricky had the third year and
he asked me to host and he booked five
bands and didn't tell anybody who they
were it was the fastest sellout last
week on sunset at the roxie ever 11
seconds no one knew who was gonna play
so i go and host and uh at the end of
the night ricky rackman scores twisted
sister
and i sat on stage i posted some um
footage of it on my instagram and i
liked it twisted sister when i was young
uh the stay hungry record and this
record here that lee was playing i was
into it but then over the 20 years or
whatever i you know i checked out and i
was bummed that i did when i watched him
play this night
i swear d snyder
[ __ ] [ __ ] it up he [ __ ] rushed
wow man i give credit where credit is it
was just
i was young and i didn't know what you
know you're [ __ ] impatient i can't
really want to be there
it wasn't really our scene so like
how important do you
when i think of music since i'm not a
huge music guy i think all that matters
to me is the music how important were
those other aspects the the costumes the
the stage like how important was that to
you as a fan sounds like it was a lot
very important
no at that time uh
i walked out of town
oh yeah when i saw him play the flute
yeah flute rock you know i i i walked
out of a few movies by that age
and the guy i hung with at the time i
still hang with him he's my daughter's
guy you know he uh
he doesn't have patience for that [ __ ]
you know he never really was a pot
smoker he did acid and went home
and had a freak out at his house you
know he never really liked that [ __ ] so
it wasn't his that's why i kind of dug
him i it wasn't really always my scene
either right there was some nights i
just want to smoke a joint just go out
and he and i went out with him and went
you know some of our friends went to see
twisted sister let's go down there
we walked in and they came out and said
twisted [ __ ] sister man
and they had makeup on i think during
the first song we just looked at each
other and tapped out wow there's an
incredible document documentary yeah
netflix
about how nobody wanted them and they
just it was just [ __ ] one thing yeah
after the other one thing after the
other friend of mine was explaining and
saying they become in the tri-state area
before they are even a record deal and
famous
they
started making thousands on the bar
circuit on their own no one would give
them a record deal or anything so
they're like [ __ ] all you guys man and
they just selling out everything all
over the place and individually become
the kings man and i think that's around
84 that that state hungry record and and
uh d snyder wrote all that stuff and
[ __ ] man that guy you know he had a
vision they were way into new york dolls
and i never got into the new york dolls
you know and that was their thing new
york dolls it was some kiss you know and
i like to kiss but not new york tills
but twisted sister boy there was a time
they were the biggest band in the world
with that i want to run
that [ __ ] thing with that guy in the
video what do you want to do with your
life that was 84 was it i think so yeah
dude all right dean when you were when
you were in a band i guess you guys are
both comedians so it might be the same
when
when you are get to that pinnacle of
like you're the biggest in the world do
you think you think it's going to last
forever or do you do you think even like
if they like all you always hear about
one hit wonders do you think they know
like all right this is probably like
only
like do you think they prepare for it or
do you think they're just delusional the
whole time
well i think that um
if it's so [ __ ] hard
it's a zillion to one to get where
some of these bands got
and you gotta know that you can only be
there for so long now if you're
delusional you're just all on drugs or
whatever but uh d snyder is a very smart
man he parlayed that into what are we
looking at 30 [ __ ] years right now on
a band that probably people thought
would last you know a week
you know so to me that is still they
made it in my eyes if you go out and you
can sell out like theaters and [ __ ]
right now 30 years later oh yeah like
that doesn't sound like they've failed
at all no how many bands got a record
deal
taped the first album and fell apart
you have no idea
the stories of this the same stories
that go with comedy
nobody knows
you see gay bird laces why do you think
gabriel laces every night it's a picture
of him in a theater with people
nobody goes out in the room like gabriel
and if you talk to gabe he'll tell you
the same thing this ain't gonna last
forever yeah i'm gonna get a piece of
this one he's very smart about it
he knows exactly there's some people
that go into then you have people that
go into with their 20s
everything falls apart when they're 30
and nobody knows who they are and they
still walk around with that [ __ ]
attitude
no that's crazy right you know who i am
you know who i am that's [ __ ] crazy
because you had 10 years of that like
why wouldn't you yeah like i i almost
you almost understand why it happens
music comedy
acting
it takes a certain
thing not to fall apart and some people
are falling apart britney spears fell
apart for [ __ ] two years and came
back
the little chick
the disney chick oh miley cyrus she fell
apart for two years and somebody had to
pull her aside and talk to her yeah uh
this cut justin
t justin bieber bieber whatever
everybody has a point you know guns and
roses yeah i remember gunjam rose is on
national television on heroin nodding
smoking a [ __ ] cigarette at the
podium like they didn't give a [ __ ] yeah
that's my when i think of guns and roses
i think of that
that's how big they [ __ ] were like
they were walking around
[ __ ] up lee i mean drooling heroin
blow
alcohol on their breath cigarettes in a
[ __ ] building that said no cigarettes
we don't give a [ __ ] what guns in the
roses is yeah we're sparking yeah i'm
saying you want to give me a ticket you
want to harass me don't matter we'll be
on an hour
in an hour you know so there's a certain
mind thing that goes with it
well you probably have to have that
certain mindset to get to that level
i would assume look at actual fracture
rose went off the deep end how long did
he disappear for now 15 13 yeah 13 years
he went to arizona and was living with a
guy that was reading stones to him and
[ __ ] you read that
i mean lee you god knows where your mind
goes can you imagine any way your girl
girl wants to suck your dick
you go to that restaurant for breakfast
that waitress she wants to suck your day
her kid loves you the band you know
she'll do anything for her i mean
that that's just one of the perks
there's no i can't imagine there's no
manual yeah
you know we i would love for for
you know they talk about all this
virtual reality i would love to go
and hang with zeppelin in 73 for six
months that'd be great right and see how
long it would take you to go to rehab
oh yeah how long would it really take
you to you went to rehab you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
these people i think they go off the
deep end john bonham died in 79 that
party started and [ __ ] since he was
three he was drinking like that and
playing the drums and your blood
pressure you know
that that thing doesn't stop
it's crazy man it's like i was talking
to you about that blind melon you know
uh
it's like here's this band that had
they put a record out it flops
totally and then mtv starts showing the
bumblebee video
you know like hey this is a cute video
and in a three month period they flop to
three million records
like th
they think they're done and they [ __ ]
crush it then the singer gets on [ __ ]
drugs
and and he can't break it
he can't [ __ ] break loose they're
sending them to rehab they're trying to
[ __ ] help him they're trying to fix
him
he writes a second record which is
monumental to me like this record is
crushing he dies three months later i
saw him a week before he died
you know and it's like it had to just
spin him out like you gotta think like
you're from indiana like he knows axel
he sells three million records you live
in hollywood in the 80s 90s people are
in the don't cry video right yeah don't
cry video
was that not him that's him
and uh
you know they were like they were like
allman brothers meets jane's addiction
and this guy's lyrics were deep man i
was reading him today because he died
saturday 31 years ago i was like
disgusting 31 31 years ago no or 20 21.
sorry yeah 95 yeah yeah yeah
21 years ago um but it's just crazy to
think like
how people you know they just
you i don't know what grabs you you know
you're just out there partying and next
thing you know it grabs you and you're
gone you know
you can't you know you look at
springsteen's longevity you look at the
stones long jump don't tell me the
stones didn't have [ __ ] problems oh
man you know they had internal problems
and drug problems look at aerosmith oh
man lee arrow smith take harold smith
yeah like i so told you
when they did the album rocks
they were so high they didn't talk to
each other
they just lived in the same house and
set what time would be down there at
three don't go down that three
from three to five i got the studio lead
i'm going down there from three to five
damn
your addiction takes you to this place
is when you signed up for this band you
just wanted to make records and make a
little bit of money maybe and play and
meet some chicks on the road and here
you are aerosmith these guys were dead
for anybody who doesn't know the
aerosmith's little story they died in
1979
and nobody heard from them till 85 but
now you're like joey so what bands do
that all the time no no no no no no i'm
talking about at the time they were the
cream of the crop and they fell apart
right in front of you perry left
the other guy left yeah that tyler was
on a [ __ ] heroin bender he couldn't
sing it was a [ __ ] horror show ah it
was a horror show and look at somewhere
along the line
they released done with mirrors which i
lit on fire yeah that's just a god awful
album i love that record there's two
songs i like i remember and i threw the
cassette away i'm like i'll never listen
to this [ __ ] again wow then the rappers
put them on the [ __ ] song and they
blew up the top and they came back and
all that music yeah is it my favorite i
also made music no it's not but i'm
happy they got back together it was a
piece of my childhood you know yeah
we've seen all these people and you ask
yourself the same story comedians
you know they go to montreal they
[ __ ] get the deal they come here
you know this is this moves fast this is
fast moving dog yeah and when this hits
this hits one minute you're doing
google's in [ __ ] missouri and the
next minute you're going to call to do
the toronto amphitheater there's 62 000
seats 6 200 seats i'm sorry yeah and
people are going to pay 48 dollars a
[ __ ] ticket for you you're like are
you serious yeah and you're still doing
that same [ __ ] you know you could
fall apart anyway haley
ego has a lot to do he don't has a
[ __ ] big point
like you can say uh drugs
but it it's always ego for the internal
battle
between i was just reading this thing
i couldn't believe it yesterday
but when they when maiden first got
bruce dickinson
and they do number of the beast record
it [ __ ] they shoot to [ __ ] the
biggest
and and steve harris the bass player
his thing was i'm always in the front in
the middle
and bruce dickinson was like third show
in like hey [ __ ] this guy i'm the singer
he started going over and just [ __ ]
smashing him over like you're over there
dude and they and steve harris admitted
they got a number one record out and
he's like i'm thinking of firing this
guy ego
because he wanted to be dead center in
the stage it's unbelievable when i'm
reading this like who's heard of a bass
player dead center you know what i mean
as you know i'm an emotional guy and i
get emotional with dumb [ __ ] sometimes
in my internal mind sometimes you just
pissed off for two days and you know
what am i pissed off yeah so the other
day i go what the [ __ ] i'm not doing
that let me go buy some albums
i go down there and i see i see 10 great
albums that day but two albums jump out
at me synchronicity oh yeah
synchronicity turned my life around i
was on a [ __ ] up spot in 83 that
summer i was a burglar i was going to
college i was working as an electrician
and that album used to soothe me i don't
know what it was that and the pretenders
were learning to crawl awesome at that
time and i got regatta leblanc yeah all
right
and i got the stones and then made in
the shade was one of my favorite of all
time because you don't stop the [ __ ]
album just don't stop i like albums that
don't stop sometimes yeah
and i'm on my way home one of my buddies
called me from jersey and i i had me we
had been missing calls for a couple days
and i called him back
and he goes where you coming from and
about listen to our best listen how much
of a child i am when it comes to music
about a week ago his brother the guy i'm
on the phone with his brother flew out
here and met with another guy from where
we're from from san diego when they went
to those concerts oh yeah now i grew up
in this kid's shed of music
and we used to have arguments about
music and [ __ ] the one that came out
here was older anthony villa and he
posted a picture of pink floyd on sunday
night oh yeah all right roger and it
says dogs
tremendous and i [ __ ] get furious
if you play dogs david gilmore better be
on that stage okay if not don't do it
you're just killing me don't [ __ ] do
it in front of me i'll tell you that
and i'm driving i'm thinking about all
this [ __ ] on the way home and i tell him
i go you know what steve
your [ __ ] brother went last week and
he posted that picture [ __ ] him and he
goes what are you talking about
what are you doing
i go you know
there's two people i can't stand the
music business i can't stand looking at
him and that's a sting yeah
and two
roger waters i really cannot stand roger
waters every time i hear him talk i want
to punch him in the [ __ ]
and for years i i liked him i really
liked him and there was one thing i
don't like yeah when he did that thing
on vh1 and they talked about roy harper
yeah singing that part oh yeah yeah yeah
on uh money right it's money
uh no it's um uh which one's pink wish
you would be by the way no which one's
people no it's from wish you were here
so it's gotta be it's a melody from that
album shine on you crazy diamond no it's
um something it's the one uh
[ __ ] oh
man
i was weird just talking about it here
and i and i never knew that roy harper
was saying that ever until like three
months ago and i was like wow it was
like something weird that had to take
him out of like he just couldn't hit it
yeah
an hour yeah an hour roger
i know how long was this going to take
and he couldn't hit it so they sent them
that roy harper was next door he never
got paid i had to get that have a cigar
that's it yeah yeah by the way which
one's pink he says that it's all right
yeah by the way which one's pink
have a cigar you're gonna go far isn't
that weird because something crazy he
couldn't hit it it sounds just like one
of those guys roy harper came in nails
it
and when [ __ ] comes back you know now
they interview him
then and now and he's like uh
you know uh
right there i just [ __ ] a whole thing
i hate came over me because i knew pink
floyd just didn't break up because there
were four geniuses there had to be a
[ __ ] reason yeah that's he said uh
whatever sang it but till this day
i think i still could have done a better
job you know what [ __ ] you punk
[ __ ] you punk i love don felder yeah
okay i love don phelps yep there's a big
deal with them and the eagles that
on
not the long run yeah he was going to
sing a song on hotel yeah california yes
and they took him to lunch and they'd
take the song with don henley and that
cost them their [ __ ] life like
but again you you're not gonna pull it
off
they eventually let keith sing keith
richards when you keep riches saying you
want to shoot yourself in the head you
know you're like what the [ __ ] is
that's the this [ __ ]
make me run
whatever
but you know yeah give me the song he
wrote 18 [ __ ] hits yep what's up lee
you always hear
comedians
like wish they were rock stars in a band
does everyone wish they were the singer
because that look or the like because
i've never i think everybody wishes they
were the star
not necessarily the singer just the main
guy you know that's how it gets into
that i think you know what i mean
especially with drummers because they
get such the short end of the stick they
got to [ __ ] they got to play drums
that [ __ ] physical and [ __ ] and then
at the end of the day they don't get any
glory unless you're you know corresponds
or keith moon but
and then they they get cut out of
royalties because they didn't write the
songs and all this [ __ ] that's why i
always get drummers on my podcast
because
without a good drummer the band
it sucks i'll show you every band that's
great they got it starts with a great
drummer
you know that's the bottom line so you
got to [ __ ] keep that guy happy man
because the chemistry is there it's
weird man when you got chemistry of four
guys
you can't just go like well let's do we
make all the money you know it's just
it's just it's gonna blow up
that's crazy i never thought about that
how drummers do get caught up they do
the music business is just as ferocious
gross as any other [ __ ] and people
think that it's that glamour thing and
you still get robbed somewhere along the
line like there's always a theft
years ago i don't remember like and i
said this on this show
somebody lived in the building that was
on tour with limp biscuit
yeah they were opening up for limp
biscuit they were telling me their story
that they don't get paid on the tour or
something yeah the album sale something
just
that i sat there and said what yeah you
guys don't get two grand or something to
open up for limb biscuits like now we
get like per diem
and something else we make our records
online i don't [ __ ] know i was like
baffled and you took this deal it's
crazy called a 360 deal
where the record companies they figured
out well nobody's gonna buy the records
anymore so we're not making any money on
these bands so what we got to do is do a
360 deal which means we get a piece of
everything in the pie we got a piece of
your toy we got a piece of your t-shirts
we get a piece of your uh if you're on
tv uh we get a piece of your songwriting
we get a piece of your record sales 360
deal and it's [ __ ] gross
you know it's it's just insane man but
that all trickles down from people
stealing records and everything you know
it just uh
the the bigwigs they're not gonna give
up their cars and mansions
so where do you think they're gonna get
the money they're gonna keep digging
until they get the money to keep the the
[ __ ]
it's not to keep the lights on it's to
keep the fourth car on and the fifth
house and the you know what i mean it's
it's insane
i never
like i said i that was one part of me
i'm
i'm an only child and that [ __ ] runs
deep
psychologically at times yeah you know i
was i always bust lee's chops lee always
says to me well
i'm thinking about my girlfriend moving
like oh wait i've known you from the
outside and i i could tell that you're a
really personal guy you don't like
people touching your [ __ ] he's never had
a roommate situation i'm the same way
i've met him he never had a struggle and
go to meet joe i live with three guys
and [ __ ] he was opening his home to you
but i could tell that at the end of the
week as long as you heat the lee knows
you're going home he's happy like yeah
this ends like in a week you could stay
on my couch are you only child too no i
have a younger brother well where does
that stem from you know i i've always
been
for me the the the thought process of
always wanting to be the star yeah
is so foreign to me
like i i i can't even comprehend it i
just
i don't know i don't want to be this i i
never wanted to be the center of
attention yeah i'm nervous i'm shy
it's just who i was it made it made me
uncomfortable i wish
i always wanted to have more friends and
be more liked but it all it like when i
found out that people in college would
come and knock on your door and just
come in yeah
[ __ ] that
there's like i like i don't want anyone
just knocking on my door i want people
to call before that i didn't like that
at all so like i i only lived on campus
for a semester i couldn't i couldn't
deal with it it was uh people would
knock on your door well they would they
wouldn't i
they they would there a little bit but
the reasons at the dorms well yeah i
just moved off campus because let's say
i was a pot smoker
you know i think
it's funny because i'm an only child i'm
50 and um
it's funny you said that because
recently i was like man maybe i'll i'll
move to new york you know because i've
been going a lot lately i was there all
august i was there last week for eight
shows i'm loving
i'm loving the stage time and i really
want to become a a better comic
and
and part of me uh my whole life
everything about me is from being an
only child but also
it has the bad side of
well new york you got to get a roommate
and i'm just like
[ __ ] man i just i can't live with
someone man it's just it's so [ __ ]
weird because when i want to go to sleep
i want to go to sleep and when i want to
be awake or play records i want to be
and
and it's like am i willing to sacrifice
my comfort
to become a better comic you know what i
mean well here's the roommate situation
okay so
we get an apartment we got a two bedroom
you know you're two doors apart
right you're trying to save dough yeah
1500 you want to get 750 out of somebody
totally
and you get like a girl in there or a
friend of yours in there you know and
they party or whatever the [ __ ] see
that's
where it ends bad yeah if you don't
right
now let's pretend i got a house
i got a three bedroom [ __ ] house i
got a back room in the back
and i know that dean is struggling as a
comic
500 as long as you clean the kitchen
dean listen do me a favor you're not
gonna see me yeah unless you hunt me
down on the other side of the [ __ ]
crib yeah and you have your own garage
and you have weights once you clean up
and all that [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
man yeah it's the people who you walk
downstairs and they're smoking in your
living room there's three strangers in
your living room and they got beer
bottles and you see the foot you know
they're about to kick the [ __ ] beer
bottle that's exactly what's gonna talk
about it's got a cigarette butt in it
which is disintegrated and you know you
know that [ __ ] look at how i tell you i
describe the situation exactly i don't
want to be a part of that yeah i don't
want to be a part of that [ __ ] i've
lived on couches
people always extended [ __ ]
courtesies to me growing up you know but
when i had a roommate situation
he was cooler than [ __ ] and then
so
we lived together two or three times and
there was never i never i would never
bring somebody over yeah like i would
never
he had a girlfriend he would go to her
house yeah that's where i would go
somewhere over there that kind of [ __ ]
right you know you leave town he watches
the dog he leaves town you watch the dog
there's always some [ __ ] thing to do
that's a great he's a professional
you're a professional everybody pays
their rent yeah nobody's doing blow or
at least they do blow do once a week in
their room
[ __ ] like that is fun you know sometimes
to come home and to talk to somebody for
10 minutes it's kind of fun especially
if they're not a comic right it's great
it never worked for me i didn't have
that many of them i only did like you're
right i never had a roommate out here um
but when i had roommates if they weren't
my friend it was great right like 10
minutes saying hi maybe watch a tv show
together have some dinner but when i
moved in with people who i knew that's
when you're [ __ ] it ended up in in
hate they start pushing buttons they
know they can get away with stuff like
oh man why are you so uptight or
whatever that kind of [ __ ] that's
starving roommate [ __ ] unless
everybody's cool and on the same page
yeah it never works it's great for a
while to somebody a friend of theirs
moves in yeah and then your [ __ ] starts
to miss your shirts are disappearing
hold on you're like [ __ ] yeah now i
gotta smack a [ __ ] that's a bad
situation i have listen i i was a single
i was an only child
i had like my own bedroom growing up
with my own tv stereo remote control
yeah cable in my room had an air
conditioner in my room all that ended
when my mom died now i had to sleep on a
bed with a guy yeah i lived in john
bender we had a double bed
we slept together two 16 year old like
two [ __ ] [ __ ] with the window open
yeah [ __ ] yeah you know what that's like
that was that was against my whole
culture in 16 years then i slept on
couches then i went to [ __ ] prison
then i got like a [ __ ] apartment i
didn't get an apartment on my own so i
was like [ __ ] 20. yeah i went to
boulder i got my first [ __ ] apartment
which was basically a room with a
mattress a walkman
yeah yeah yeah i got a tv after a while
i got cable beside i didn't know nothing
about [ __ ] nothing i had been
sleeping on couches all my [ __ ] life
yeah
i i lived in a warehouse
with uh another band member where we
rehearsed
so i i lived in the
office of the warehouse and then he
built like a wooden loft inside the
studio and he slept in there
but he would he would do a little
[ __ ] marching powder and just [ __ ]
practice guitar night not plugged in but
i could still hear to just be like
and after like four hours i was like
dude man you gotta [ __ ] stop you know
what i mean
yeah because it was really quiet in the
warehouse at night you know we lived in
an industrial area and you could just
hear it pick it just
and you would just try to learn stuff
metallica you know
just like that low but i would have to
get up work in construction at like six
in the morning i'd be like two you know
and then this stuff just wears on you
man it's just like
it's tough man i mean it's like you know
it's uh it's stupid complaining about it
and with me guess who my worst roommate
was who of all time yeah
my mom oh
no class oh
your mom no class no class no respect
we had just this conversation the other
night lee i and my friend no respect
no class actually woke me up when i was
14 with a girl downstairs
coming down to me to dance with that
type of [ __ ] yeah my mom would knock him
don't go don't there's people downstairs
they want to come down dress up come
down i would come down have to talk to
people four in the morning they'd be all
[ __ ] coked up yeah [ __ ]
i'd be giving out hugs they'd be giving
me 20s and [ __ ]
my mom would bring me like a cuban
sandwich from the cuban place down the
corner and then that she was rude yeah
or she would cook
at four in the morning people come over
and she loud laughing loud loud music
yeah rude my mom was rude in fact i went
home about not this time like maybe
three times ago three four years ago i
went home and i went to see a a person
that had grown up around the house
and she goes you know when i think about
your mother i think a one night like in
1970.
she goes my kids were [ __ ] young you
know she was young they were like 14 11
8.
and he goes i heard my husband renee
your mom and your stepdad
coming to my house and your mom's tone
in her voice
she thought it was one in the afternoon
oh yeah right she goes that thing goes
that's the night i understood your mom
like i always liked your mom because she
didn't give a [ __ ]
yeah i just didn't give a [ __ ] i had to
say the same scene man a lot a lot of
late night parties at my house you know
just carol king on sunday morning you
know
that meant the all-night bender was over
the boone's farm and the [ __ ]
colombian weed and the [ __ ] you know
what i mean just the i remember my mom
we lived in this house man and uh my mom
had she had a another woman living with
us the woman died in a [ __ ] corvette
car crash drunk driving his chick named
cindy but we had like a roommate
you know i mean like an adult my mom had
an adult roommate like you know so it's
like another person living at our house
because we were just we you know needed
to make ends meet and it was just
it was just weird like i i think back in
my childhood you know
i said this i said this to someone
recently i was looking at some paperwork
my mom sent me and
there was a stepdad in there i didn't
even remember
until i was looking at the paperwork
it's like holy [ __ ] i forgot my mom
married this guy when i was like five
maybe six how long was it together for
like a year you know what i mean i
completely don't even remember that
isn't that crazy
it's just like
it's just it's just wild man when you
when you look back at how everybody
the people my friends that i see how
they grew up and then how i grew up i
love how i grew up but it was uh pretty
[ __ ] uh
she'd be out a lot so i'd be alone
that's why i don't think i can deal with
roommates i learned
to be cool with being on my own i love
it
i love it
i would wake up at six and that meant i
would be alone for like three or four
hours yeah and that's always been my
world like last night i got up at five
this morning sunday i got up at five
i was up for two [ __ ] hours before
anybody got up yeah i smoke some dope i
drink some coffee
i take a shower
you know it's your own little [ __ ]
world you put on some soft music you
read a couple [ __ ] segways free jokes
you look over your podcast whatever yep
i've always enjoyed
i love i'll tell you what guys i like
going to movies by myself me too
terry i've been married twice and i've
had girlfriends and i got great friends
but
i think at times my best friend has
always been my solitude and i'm
embarrassed to say
listen there's nothing better than me
going for a movie by myself
and before i go i roll a joint i got a
chinese one of those lunch specials yeah
like the movies used to start like at 12
15. yep and you go to the chinese
restaurant when it opened at 11.
11 30. you got your little [ __ ] lunch
special shredded [ __ ] beef with the
pot rice
some [ __ ] pot stickers of egg roll
and you went to that movie by yourself
because i realized that sometimes this
might be selfish
late meet me at the movies at 12 15.
also at 12 15 i got a [ __ ] call from
lee yeah i'm three blocks away the lady
in front of you know and i'm not saying
lee i'm just yeah yeah i get it it's it
it always works out like that for me
late you know oh you're late at the chat
listen they talked during the movie i
don't i don't give a [ __ ] if you say
something during the movie i'm too high
i won't even hear you
yeah yeah i'm definitely i turned the
death button on that's the least time
you know i make sure i sit next to the
door that lemonade comes with me one of
these art students comes in there
shooting they gave him a d and [ __ ]
uh design i don't need to be shot by
some [ __ ] art student with a bb gun
yeah so i sit next to the door but
i love that [ __ ] and they tell and i
heard that people who eat by themselves
die
like they die heart attacks or they die
younger and listen i'm gonna die younger
and i'll tell you why
because first off late
if i see leo on a ranch i'm already
upset you know what i'm saying and if
i'm in general for years i wouldn't say
that
in my mind like oh look at his mutt
like not only does he owe me 25 [ __ ]
dollars
not only is he a [ __ ] mutt but on top
of that he drinks ranch dressing like
i'm judgmental yeah this [ __ ] i don't
want to know about you you know what i'm
saying i don't care how you eat i don't
care if the food drips down your [ __ ]
face yeah it's what you invite to that
[ __ ] table it depresses me okay like
if you eat hummus or you order like a
bad entree out of place like i expect
you to be to know [ __ ] about this place
before we go in there right yeah and i
know you know the answers i like i like
the places where people look at you
they look like a [ __ ] smoke and they
look at me at 300 pounds and they go
joey when i go in that place with you
what should i eat
and under pressure they crack and they
get the worst thing on the menu yeah
yeah yeah this [ __ ] look over here
they crack
listen get the [ __ ] gumbo i need to
rub the crab on your face you've never
had gummy before well this is but you
had the crap yeah it's amazing yeah it's
amazing yeah i can have a conversation
with lee he'll tell me where he's going
to watch that oh my god
and i'm going to say like oh how was it
i don't know how he decided to go to
this other place to eat dump
and i don't understand none of that [ __ ]
so before it affects my [ __ ] lunch
yeah you know what i'm saying before you
order pizza at a bad [ __ ] place yeah
right in front of me and cuz that'll
ruin my movie now i don't want to even
sit next to the movie
like that's how upset i get with all
that [ __ ] so i just avoided it you never
brought food into the movie theater like
you said you stopped the chinese place i
would stop at the chinese place better
bring it in listen if i smell your
disgusting dumpling at the movie theater
i will take that chopstick from you and
i will stick it right in your tit you
understand me that's aggressive that's
the gross i don't want to smell food if
it's just a movie because food always
smells like foot in a movie theater and
i was moving
on a plane people have no idea
how bad that [ __ ] mcdonald's smells
at eight in the morning oh dude i was i
was flying first class once i got lucky
uh and and then they were like oh yeah
you're upgraded and i'm first class and
and on comes uh
michael bolton he was uh married to that
star uh that was on like tesla that was
one of those shows yeah so they come on
and um it's we're flying to london and i
just sit down i get my [ __ ]
headphones on them ready and they whip
out their mcdonald's right like nuggets
and all this [ __ ] in first class and
then they must have been like on some
sleeping pills or something as soon as
we took off they fell asleep in the
mcdonald's the bag the [ __ ] was just
rolling around and first class on the
floor and stuff and it just smelled like
[ __ ] death you know like just foot
smell like foot you know the onions and
mcdonald's like those onions grown like
in a radiation farm no like the onions
at mcdonald's we eat the onions and
mcdonald's they have a different taste
of them and if they touch your skin
it's like getting [ __ ] hindu sweat on
you
it's like getting [ __ ] disguised
something that you cannot describe
what happens when you get no disrespect
to hindus you know i love you
[ __ ] when we were kids one time
it's a long story
uh what the [ __ ] are we talking about
the onions at mcdonald's yeah yeah so
people don't know those dehydrated type
onions
wreak differently even like white castle
like you don't know what life is until
you wake up in a room where they had
white castle wow like something like i
had a he wasn't my roommate he's my
brother and this [ __ ] used to
bring white castle home and eat it and
i'd be sleeping
and i'd wake up in the morning and i'd
look around that room with the smell
between your pants and your shirt from
the bar yeah you know because we grew up
when people were allowed to smoke yeah
so when you walked into a bar and then
already had the smoke in it from the
night before plus 80 people smoking a
[ __ ] cigarette even if you didn't
smoke you'd walk out of there next
morning hungover lee you don't know what
life is later you're hungover
you get up you're gonna put your pants
on
and you could smell this cigarette
coming out of your pants
i used to hang my jacket in the garage
guys it's [ __ ] hard oh thank god they
stop smoking in those places
one part of me is like you know what man
i hate to be i would listen why have a
cocktail you can't [ __ ] smoke and say
right you know what i'm saying i'm
looking out for the [ __ ] guy who goes
out and does a bumper coke i don't want
to [ __ ] leave after i do a bump to go
outside to smoke yeah i don't want to do
that that's annoying that's [ __ ]
annoying especially if you get a little
paranoid you're outside like cops are
out there now when you're in a bar on
coke you feel like you're in the
submarine like in a safe zone
i would wake up in that basement
apartment had a little window for
ventilation
and between his feet my feet
the jeans the shirt and the white castle
oh god it was [ __ ] hard just a [ __ ]
stew he would get onion rings to really
make it bad though
you know it's just all that stuff makes
me sick yeah so as i got stronger in my
life
you know
i mean i'm in seattle i went to call for
a roommate situation the girl i was
dating was a [ __ ] nightmare
and one afternoon i go you know what now
i'm going to do this in the middle of
the month i got to stop what the [ __ ]
i'm doing to go look for an apartment
with no [ __ ] car wow
and i'm asking joshua for rides and i
remember going to one place that was
great
the only problem was the guy had like a
great name and he had [ __ ]
everywhere in this [ __ ] house i tell
you how bad it was as the guy was
showing me the room in the corner there
was a piece of [ __ ]
that had dehydrated from one of those
four shits to like three inches and he
didn't pick it up before the roommate
came over to little check it out nothing
and i said you know what that's [ __ ]
weird out there and i go you know what
yeah i'm moving oh i like the place it
was really accessible to me
something something i went i got my bags
i went over there i put them down
this [ __ ] room this house
the more i walked
east from that room yeah it got worse oh
and worse and it was like the people the
horse was pissing yeah and they would
let it lit sit there for three days and
then pick it up and finally i looked in
the living room and sure enough my
suspicions there was a pile of [ __ ]
piss
that they had left you know
i went i got my bags i think i called
josh wolfe yeah and i go josh you gotta
do me a favor i can't live with this
[ __ ] kid why not and when i lived
here in l.a oh my god
when i moved here in l.a
i me and the girl broke up and there's
always one of those things you break up
and now i got to go get a new pad yeah
and some guy at the comedy store that i
kind of knew from the comments was like
man me and my wife just broke up this is
the perfect room for you like where is
he goes it's like i'm vermont
oh yeah and we'll show you guys
what he goes yeah you're gonna love it
oh my god
i get over it it's one of those we don't
have air conditioning apartments we just
open the windows oh right there
seal there
can i even put it on up on that
conditioner because none of the
building's too old so the thing will
blow that's why we had to take them all
out wow the circuits are blowing he took
me into the back room and it was just
[ __ ] disgusting did they try to lie
do you like we opened there's a great
circular they always say that i remember
chick told me that when i first came
here uh i was in uh silver lake
place was blaze and she goes we get a
nice cool breeze off the reservoir it's
like what are you talking about it's
only 70 out right now and i'm [ __ ]
burning up in here no no no no
at one point i don't know what happened
i had a roommate
up to
maybe in the comedy game listen when you
get here
when i first got here i lived with a
girl
then we broke up 80 [ __ ] times she
was a dirty [ __ ]
she broke up 80 [ __ ] times and got
back together so it was always the
dilemma so for a while i just lived on
josh wolf's couch yeah and i threw him a
little cash i bought groceries from time
to time you're a [ __ ] feature act bro
yeah you know but in those days it was a
200 plane ticket to new york
oh yeah 200 flat round tripoli right now
249 virgin i've been flying it non-stop
249 i signed up for their like uh their
their uh notices and they'll just hit me
sail tomorrow for two hours i'm grabbing
these flights 249 round trip round trip
man it was 2 40
no jfk dude come on i'm flying from lax
to jfk
on virgin twice now 249. you got it you
get your number in your register there's
a frequent flyer yeah i just have signed
up as a frequent flight so next time you
fly
yeah buy a ticket for 249 and then tell
them you want to upgrade to main cabin
select not first class yeah yeah yeah i
saw it for it was like 49 bucks to
upgrade you're crazy great great that's
where the pimps will sit [ __ ] great
if you're a real pimp yeah and you don't
want to fight first class you ain't got
the pocket
you buy a cheap ticket at virgin
register you fly a lot if you fly a lot
always look at virgins routes that's
great register and then just buy the
cheap ticket and then the night before
12 hours 12 hours before yeah even if
you got to get up at three in the
morning who gives a [ __ ] you get up 3
a.m boom call them and go i want to
upgrade to main cabinet select what do
you want give me an aisle window boom
that's a great bargain
you sit there you don't get off you
don't get up one time they give you
quality food oh you press a button
there's movies they got the killer
lighting
become a frequent fly on [ __ ] virgin
and you know what their flights are
difficult sometimes for me yeah like i
really wanted to take them to boston
they only got to play like five places
they wanted
699 for boston wow well i think they got
my cookies lee
because they went in 1999 for first
class whoa i always look at the regular
ticket i look at first class i see what
the difference is yeah
delta wanted like seven and two some
plane tickets were cheap the weirdest
thing was
i called delta and delta had a plane
ticket when i had to cancel for oddball
yeah but they reused it and they said we
found some other money so the ticket is
free and we owe you a check for 13 to
boston wow so i'm going to boston for
[ __ ] one day i don't know how i
scored it wow so now i think maybe they
made a mistake but not delta don't make
mistakes mitch
they don't make mistakes like that it
was too much of a mistake so and i keep
checking it no it's that virgin's great
man [ __ ] they got a flight
on um
their red eye is at 11 30
at night it's great one thing i like
about virgin is they only have a few
places they're going so the flights are
never late you know they show up that
leaves at 11 30. so you get there you
get into new york at like uh 7 30 their
time in the morning yeah slept the whole
way that is not a bad time to get into
the new year not at all it's perfect
especially if you could eat breakfast at
jfk that's right yeah
who the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with yeah right because you're gonna
have to steam it out anyway yeah your
luggage is gonna take 45 minutes yeah
yeah your hotel's not gonna be ready no
7 45 yeah that's a long [ __ ] wait for
your hotel though now i know but you
know what
i call ahead the day before to the hotel
and i say look i got a meeting i need an
early check-in man come on and and i'll
give you a shout out on the podcast or
whatever uh
one of the guys in new york was telling
me that uh dudes tell the hotels look i
got the big podcast to give you a shout
out or whatever that's all right yeah
and they chat early check it so i got a
i got a 10 30 check-in
last uh last week when i was there and i
was like this is great you know i was
only in a hotel one day and then ari let
me stay at his house while he was on the
road so it's just perfect
perfect run man
you're living a good life now this is
nice what you're doing oh
you're 50 you're going you're trying to
become bi-coastal just listen you gotta
do what ari does just eliminate the
winter in new york that's what i'm doing
that's gonna eliminate the winter
totally come you know because june is
great in new york yeah may is
sensational
april is tremendous september is
brilliant oh i was there last week yeah
october is brilliant oh october
september new york city are brilliant
you can still move it light jacket once
november comes in that cold weather and
i know these guys it gets like warm in
january joey it was 63 today it's
january [ __ ] february still around the
corner [ __ ]
but never fear room
yeah yeah the snake lies coil the
nipples [ __ ] you know what i did uh i
was with my buddy marcus price who works
for hannibal and uh he had two
italian scooters mopeds the ones with
the wheels the 70s ones those crazy ones
you know the pooks
and uh he said yo i know you love coney
island so it's sunday it's open it's a
75 out he goes let's ride these out from
brooklyn we rode from brooklyn to coney
island surface streets like a beastie
boys video
just seeing all of brooke and pull up
the [ __ ]
to the cyclone parked them locked them
up
rode this [ __ ] two times took some
photos got back on and rode back in this
perfect weather and then did spots at
the stand that night i was like this is
[ __ ] great you know
like life is good man
you know there's uh there's a couple
parts to comedy and i know that there's
a couple parts to music you know i know
that
there was bands that went on on tour for
two years didn't stop touring them
recorded while they were on the [ __ ]
road
then one day there's a thing called the
kid
and you're like listen this is ending
with or without me you guys can keep
going yeah but i gotta go home make a
pit stop for a few weeks and see the
kids and whatever and really
you know so there's three levels to this
at this point right now
let's pretend i lived
somewhere like tennessee where i had
terry's parents there all week and terry
was entertained with her sisters and
you know what i'm saying
i can leave for a couple days i go let's
do a monday [ __ ] it
i get on the right monday night tonight
11 30 do six on a monday and get the
[ __ ] out of here
spend a week in new york first off
i would miss them too much at this point
yeah like i would miss i like what's
going on right now i like my road how i
keep it
it's very simple i'm not trying to kill
myself yep i'm not trying to prove
nothing you know we were talking about
ego before we're talking about roger
borders and how
till this day every time i see sting in
an interview i think how he took one of
the world's greatest band down
because of your [ __ ] ego and then and
you think of you know
roger waters is
as war with everybody and i think about
mick jagger he's as egotistical as they
come totally but he's like business is
business yeah yeah you know business is
business yeah you know and and even in
comedy i i
i've never let myself get into that dumb
[ __ ] i keep that out of the way man i
took that out of the way as a young man
i got that [ __ ] out of the way ego
there's no reason to have ego it's not
gonna [ __ ] do nothing for you you
know yeah
i don't give a [ __ ] i go i do some [ __ ]
that who gives a [ __ ] bro yeah i'm just
trying to be funny and have a good time
that's all i'm trying to do too man
that's it yeah that's why i'm doing new
york a lot because let me ask you
something about this joey because i i
don't get to talk to a lot of guys that
work as much as you do like you know
burr and marin and you and uh and guys
like that but
i find that uh as i i travel around
does this happen to you where your stuff
works a lot of the time but then you'll
get to some rooms and your stuff's not
working it's like medium laughs you know
just the
somewhere around 30 minutes they're kind
of out does that happen to you
absolutely is that for headlining you
mean yeah yeah absolutely
we've had discussions lee and i
of what happens during a special yeah
okay
uh 20 years ago when you first started
watching specials
you took a ride with the special you
took a ride but always remember at about
the 30 minute mark yeah
[ __ ] starts coming into your mind
where's my daughter yeah
am i gonna do the homework tonight
that's where all the other sensory [ __ ]
comes into your mind
and you disappear now it's up to the
comic
you know how many specials do you watch
rate 10 specials yep whether it's andrew
dice clay delirious take a george carl
in one ck take ck take prior at some
point no matter how funny they are
life comes back to you the coke wears
off yeah yeah the joint wears off yeah
well the comedy you don't get sucked in
anymore the excitement
and somewhere for eight or nine minutes
or ten minutes you lose them now it's up
to the comic
it's up to the comic now
what made it listen we all headlined at
the six year mark yeah that's where i'm
at right okay but you say to yourself
you know what i was pretty good as i
headlined no you're not now wait till
you get to the 10-year mark and get a
little bit better in the 15-year mark
and the 20-year mark
like i tell people i then became i
didn't become a headliner for 17 years
because
i didn't become a headline until four
years ago
yeah
but i had been doing comedy 20 [ __ ]
years i didn't become a true headliner
where you have them
and and now you you become a
professional
you're a boxer
it's a 60-minute bout yeah okay
which means i got to have endurance
yeah i gotta learn how to keep range
in the [ __ ] this guy's dangerous
between the fourth and seventh round
that's why i start to taper off
yeah yeah i gotta get momentum again in
the [ __ ] eighth round you know what
i'm saying so this is what becoming a
headliner does yeah it teaches you
whether you're going to be aggressive
with the bob and weave with to stay back
make believe you're entertained you just
got him you're just playing a magic
trick you see this right hand it's a
magic trick he's looking for you know
what i'm saying yeah and then you beat
him up again and that's it you get the
[ __ ] out of there yeah wow that was
amazing no it really wasn't big closer
yes something story in the middle oh
yeah something to lullaby always make a
knowledge of the waitress
acknowledged 50 250. i just had two
drinks and a [ __ ] bag of nachos
disgusting hummus yeah so that goes into
your mind yeah i'm gonna figure this out
yeah is this piece of [ __ ] worth it was
this comic worth that you know so now
you got another bump there so you got
about 12 minutes to [ __ ] with them yeah
now you open a can of whip ass on them
and to be honest that's what they're
going to remember
totally it's a lot of whip ass
so it's pretty impressive
getting there and getting that bob and
weave listen for this special i didn't
know how to have a closer yeah that's
what you were telling i had to talk to
him yeah i just talked to him
why not why [ __ ] around and give him
something that ain't yeah for a year and
a half i had a great closure that got
stronger and stronger and stronger but
because i did it so much on the road i
didn't want to be put on especially i
felt like i would insult people if i had
showed up with that [ __ ] material wow
so i didn't do
it and even today on the road
i will hit you with 45 minutes of new
material yeah but i used that clothes
because it was a joke we all had a great
time from the podcast and a lot of
people that start liking me is because
of that story they they
acknowledge that story so lee was tony
bennett cox sucker
lee dog
he's got [ __ ] to do with people to see
[ __ ] d del rizzi
oh [ __ ] so if i won't let me play this
song hold on
jesus lee you're slipping you should
have been on point with this isn't it i
haven't had it all right
watch the bag you're breaking people's
ear lobes oh [ __ ] sorry
these people gonna complain [ __ ] dean
delrissie [ __ ] up my [ __ ] hello
grabbed the water
thanks for having me again man no we got
to do you once a month i i was going to
call reigning i forgot to call mr bozo
he's been doing a lot lately on facebook
yeah he's got a little band going on
it's pretty impressive listen
yes lee you
always gets me on a monday con suckers
four or five years we're doing this
podcast we stay consistent to tell you
on monday
tony
pick up the bennett
what do you think you're dealing with
lisa
lee how's that acid it's going pretty
good yeah feel it uh i'm starting to i
feel little chemicals in my stomach
yeah i feel like i got a big lunch
acid for it
leaves in much better shape this time
than last time oh that was strong last
time linda blair came and visited him
his head was turning backwards
that was a lot last time i loved it
so before that happens and i lose it
completely no i'm just teasing i know
well before i lose completely regardless
because we had a lot
dean you said you'd uh work construction
yeah i know joey did too i
there's they're rebuilt they're building
a
place across from my house they're
building a new house i don't know what
it is right but it's pretty i've gotten
to see the whole process like they tore
something down they got the thing level
and then they they've been building
level by level and it's i'm not good at
that yeah and just like
normally i don't look at it but
sometimes when i'm stoned i look at i'm
like it's pretty cool
to get to like see
like you're doing something like that
you're building a house i hated it
but it was the only job that you could
have with long hair back when i when i
was young i was telling people this
there was three things you couldn't go
in disneyland with long hair
there was a rule like no men with long
hair like it you know uh
and you couldn't get a job so it was
construction or or uh landscaping or
telephone sales those are the three gigs
you could get with long hair
in you know the
70s 80s man now
like i always say i don't even think i
got enough tattoos to work at chipotle
now you know what i mean i remember when
i got one tattoo my mom was like you're
never gonna have a real job and i was
like good you know and she was like
trying to scare me but i was like now
chipotle they got them they got the menu
on their neck you know what i mean it's
like holy [ __ ] the world's changed you
know
but i hated construction because it was
like you had to get up at like five oh
yeah i i'm sure it sucks i'm sure it
sucks like i'm sure there's a lot of
people who listen who work construction
i'm sure it's not fun
a lot of people love it well i mean yeah
they take pride in their work i'm sure
it's like a very hard but it was just
it's just cool to see the whole process
i loved it i loved it i loved it
and the messier the better oh yeah i was
a stone mason and bought in aspen
colorado up in high altitude you get
there you got to take a tarp off the
brick and there's three inches of snow
on it you gotta take the tarp off the
[ __ ] concrete you gotta take a tarp
off the sand that's held down by cinder
blocks all right then you gotta get a
bucket and turn that around and you
gotta [ __ ] get a machine and get that
put gasoline in the thing yeah and then
get that [ __ ] started
and that's what you hear and then you
get the hose you throw it in there you
throw a [ __ ] scoop of rocks in there
16 scoops of rock a bag of 80-pound
[ __ ] concrete
and [ __ ] 16 scoops of sand and [ __ ]
or whatever the [ __ ] you're making i'm
sorry no rocks you would throw like one
thing of rock in
16 scoops of sand yeah and a bag of 80
pound concrete and then once it was
great and mixed [ __ ] up there three
three and a half minutes you took it out
with your hand you looked you gave it to
the stone masons then you had to empty
it make another one empty that one make
another one and while you are emptying
it get four wheel barrels and sand and
shovel four [ __ ] wheelbarrows and
then run them off for eat stonemason
empty on them and bring them back and
then have his [ __ ] bricks cut up so i
would have to have the whole row of
bricks for him especially whether he was
left-handed or right-handed all set up
for him with his tools yeah all right i
would have to have that like let's say
the job started at eight i would have to
get that 7 30 and do all that i was a
lone warrior like a like a pre-med 19
years old stoned to the gills yeah with
a [ __ ] walkman on with those thick
speakers with the cushions oh yeah yeah
what a [ __ ] hooded sweatshirt a hat a
[ __ ] winter jacket gloves with the
fingers cut out some judas he's going
through this priest going and i go out
there every morning start up all that
[ __ ]
and then
lee why are you doing all this you still
gotta build a scaffold
so you're building scaffold for the
other side you're cleaning off all the
rocks you don't want ever in your life
want something to go joey more more [ __ ]
sucker oh yeah that's embarrassing to a
guy like me you shouldn't have to tell
me to do [ __ ] mortar yeah so the
mortar always has to keep coming you're
always scooping you know you're looking
at the end of the day you've picked up
30 bags 80 [ __ ] times you know when i
did that with roofing
the only thing that made me quit
construction was money all the time yeah
money at the end of the week you looked
at it and you said you know what i
helped a bid that now
30 years ago in this country you learned
to trade lee tell the way so once i
grabbed you the first year was gonna be
eight bucks an hour
but after the first year i give you 12
15. you know what i'm saying you get
some tools
and the more you show me is the more i
show you if you want to come to work and
pick a paper then come to work and pick
a paper good luck
but if you're going to come to working
good uh boss can i put that tv up today
with [ __ ] dean yeah put it up you're
just saving me 800. i could throw you an
extra yardstick you're following me yeah
that's how you make money and you get in
there and lay the brick and learn how to
do that there were schmucks that
they'd be giggling man last night there
was a great party last night what are
you talking about thinking about union
wages here you're behind those throwing
up bricks smoking cigarettes of this
idiot talking about twitter
yeah what to get in there go pick up
those bricks get dirty
[ __ ] yeah i got that i was framing it
was piece work so you got paid by how
many [ __ ] sticks you put up man you
know what they pay in those days for
that [ __ ] i can't remember but i think
it was around 30 an hour you could make
you know if you were [ __ ] moving your
ass and and we had a team four of us so
if one guy was lacking the other dude to
be on you like what the [ __ ] are you
doing you know because they were only
there to make money and if you were just
like slow
you know because we're like
we'd be going as a team and we're
building condos so it'd be four of us
and we're building this whole section of
these condos and you know and the faster
you work the more money you made and to
me man most of the times i'd be hungover
played gigs the night now a day you
didn't give a [ __ ] man yeah just
painting the fuel that addiction oh yeah
man i think the few of the i did that i
remember being
18 and committing a crime and the rumor
was they were looking for me so my
friend kurt d lorenzo god bless his soul
took me down to uh glass barrel and i
lived with him for like six weeks
and after three days you know
[ __ ] like us we gotta get out
of the house yeah and the first thing i
saw
when people are looking for you you have
to get out of the house i was two hours
away from where the action was yeah it
was like on the pre-internet yeah this
is pretty interesting you know people
didn't go fast
let's take a picture go [ __ ] yourself
you know you put on the hooded
sweatshirt you kept walking oh my god
i'd rob somebody something happened this
was like uh
this was before we did no
this was after colorado no no no no i'm
lying to you guys this was before the
jewelry store i i robbed a drug deal and
they were looking for me so like for
about a couple weeks i just went down to
philly yeah my everybody kept asking me
what are you doing in philly going to
college i wasn't going to college i was
living on curt's couch watching tv
smoking great dope eating cheese steaks
lifting weights with this kid having a
great time
i don't even know what the point of the
[ __ ] story is and i oh
after three days yeah you sit there the
coke wears off
the [ __ ] wears off you know you
stand at somebody's house as a guest
he's cool as [ __ ] but you're not going
to ask him for 20 bucks to get weed or
eat so you got to make a living you know
what i'm saying yeah i said let me get
up and walk around and see what's
happening and i bumped into these dudes
that had a conveyor belt
and they were looking up at the sky it
was the coldest day of [ __ ] year
and these savages are looking up at the
sky and they're putting 80 pound rolls
of roofing oh yeah yeah yeah the guitar
paper the tar paper you're putting on
the thing
and that just happened you know me i'm
an [ __ ] in heat
i go up to the guy and i go hey man you
guys looking for help and he goes what
can you do like i could do this yeah and
he goes are you that strong i go look at
me i'm a [ __ ] 19 i'm an animal yeah
and he goes i'll pay you 12 an hour
or 75 a day it was really weird i go
[ __ ] yeah yeah he goes when do you want
to start i go let me go back and get
some workbooks i'll be right there those
days work boots with my main shoe that's
how i kicked windows yeah right
i didn't have a hammer or nothing
for about four days he made me do that
[ __ ] it was a nightmare yeah just pick
up rolls off a truck put him up there
this was a huge roof yeah this roof went
on for days
and the guys on the roof i felt sad for
because they had to get a truck put the
rolls on and then carry it for the
length of a football field ah because
you couldn't go back there with the
trucks it was something real there was
trees or something
you could not go back there so they
wanted to start the roof back there and
work themselves this way oh so they're
walking with the 80 pound rollers with
the 80-pound [ __ ] rolls on a truck
three of them pushing like [ __ ]
slaves
it was a horror show then i got promoted
to up there
up there wasn't bad if you took the
thing off the roll yeah and you put it
on let me tell you something i lost
15 pounds of baby fat
in two [ __ ] weeks you made a little
money and you ate with guys and you
bought lunch
then i see a future in it
that's what scared me going
i gotta do this one on 50. oh right come
pull up with my truck with a warm cup of
coffee yeah cause you always see the
foreman and you can see them they're
like oh
hey dean grab that for me wait and
you're like that guy's body is destroyed
destroyed destroyed and i listen it's
how this country got built totally i
have nothing against them i just yeah i
did the electrical trades i did [ __ ]
all every type of construction from
[ __ ] uh i got a job once spraying
buildings with that [ __ ] no
the [ __ ] uh stucco yeah the stucco
yeah they paid i did that for about two
weeks i did everything i did you know
what i did man and i actually kind of
liked this one i did it for about three
years
uh the giant mower driving the mowers
for like uh you know condo
lawns and football fields and and uh it
was uh commercial landscaping but it was
it wasn't putting them in it was
maintenance so i in the morning put the
[ __ ]
the thing on my truck it was amazing
like i didn't know how to do any of this
stuff the guy hires me and i'm out
driving a truck with a trailer on the
back you know you got you got to learn
how to drive that [ __ ] you know it's
opposite and then get somewhere and mow
this [ __ ] massive field you know
in the sun and then load it up go do
another one i did that for a few years
man
i like that because i was i was by
myself what just like you walk man you
know i loved all that [ __ ] yeah i got a
job one summer doing that [ __ ] with you
they call it landscaping
but it's really excuse me it's really uh
digging eight inches and putting a pipe
in with holes in it peripheral pipe i
forgot what it's called don't be mad at
me construction guys
and i did this all over aspen they were
building something i can't remember what
it was and this guy was paying me great
like irrigation lines you're putting
that [ __ ]
i don't remember what it was two inch
three inch
four inch perforated pipe right it's
called so the water leaks out of it
there's some [ __ ]
and at first the guy at that time
everybody paid your tent up and asked me
he started me at like 12 and he shot me
up to 15
and he goes listen do you mind if i
leave you alone
and i'll look
what do i need you here for yeah watch
me do what dig and go all the way down
the block with this pipe all day i got
to walk i got a bag of reefer yeah and i
got breath mints i could be here all
[ __ ] day i'll be here from 6 00 a.m
when you're that young what do you give
a [ __ ] totally i did everything those
years everything i tried everything
wallpaper i couldn't get my that cocaine
eye i got the drifter yeah my right eye
drifts is between the stroke and the
cocaine and the [ __ ] early youth i
couldn't hang the wallpaper straight i
mean i did it all i was painting i
painted for a year i painted i was a
great painter i didn't
again
leave me alone for three hours give me a
thing
i got the best job i had was a snowmass
village for vpn village property
management
my friend said that they would hire
people to do piecework at your own rate
they would give you a list your own
personal list
and you would look at it and they and on
it would be like 900 worth of work yeah
so it was up to you when did you want to
pick up the [ __ ] check
they had the paint in front of the
apartment or yet it was going tape so i
would do the same thing on saturdays and
sundays
i would [ __ ] do that but case other
joints that's when i was a burglar yeah
i know the [ __ ] motivation of the
people when they left when they came
back because all the apartments were
together so i was there for like two
weeks
i would watch watch watch watch make
little notes and [ __ ] and after the
paint job finished ba-boom i hit him
about a week later nobody knows
if you hit them while you're there they
know it's you oh yeah yeah you're
eyeballing them while you're painting
them yeah i'd wake up a week late nobody
knew nothing i knew they had a back door
they had a cat whatever the [ __ ] they
had i knew lee how you feeling over
there i'm feeling nervous about a new
worker i see now in my apartment oh
yeah yeah always you know you know what
i had i think this job got me uh this
job got me into uh
performing
was uh i was selling magazine
subscriptions in front of supermarkets
uh and they pay you by how many you
could get so me and my buddy were there
and people would be walking up and back
hey man uh we're running half off on
magazines right now and you just show
them this far pamphlet and had like
every mag on the planet tv guide people
[ __ ] you know us magazine rolling
stone spin everything and you get guys
to buy it was so absurd in front of
grocery stores for like five hours a van
would just drop us off and then come
pick us up how many you get i sold 20 of
them you know she was like
oh this [ __ ] was we could sell
anything yeah lee once we get the rhythm
to something you're dead yeah you're
dead and i knew how to spot certain
people i once i was always a
construction guy i was a construction
guy until about 1984 then i dabbled to
bartending yeah
and then that that i don't know there
was something about bartending
that bothered me deep down inside i
gotta be honest here i always thought it
would be a dream of mine to open up a
bar and serve cheesesteaks and have my
leg on the ice machine archie's place
yeah i'm like that's that's just i don't
want to listen to that i don't want to
be in that
if mom and then somebody introduced me
to sales
well the first time i got introduced to
sales really was on my own when you sell
newspaper ads when you deliver
newspapers door to door
i think that's the first time you got to
knock on people's doors let me ask you a
question you only get sunday
why can't i give you the whole week and
save you two dollars a month you know
and you're like okay
yeah can you bring it up my stairs if
you bring it up my stairs i'll buy it
right now okay
done and that was it i made a note on
the [ __ ] thing bringing up the
[ __ ] stairs
you're 12. paper wrap a paper right you
learned how to sell but you didn't know
the baby you weren't no [ __ ] luke
feldman no you're not selling the abc's
or selling yeah and then somewhere
oh
i don't think cars was the first thing i
sold
there was something before cars i sold
and i always thought it was interesting
but i always thought we were rip-off i
always thought salesmen were ripping
well sales
it's really weird to me
about sales like you sold cars i sold
harley-davidson's
and
everyone thinks you're lying to him
so after a while you start feeling like
am i like a piece of [ __ ] here yeah i
mean because they're like come on man i
know you're [ __ ] you know you could
do
every time they think that you're
getting totally rich on this last deal
and they think that like
you're no matter what no matter what you
do they think this guy's ripping us off
i swear to god isn't it crazy like sales
because you got to be a little bit like
hustling
you know of course to get somebody to
buy i've never seen a guy just walk in
and go you know the red one's great and
they go all right and they sign up you
have to be like i like red because
[ __ ] you know it just shines it looks
great or whatever
and and when you give them that then
they're like this guy's full of [ __ ]
it's so weird sales right
well it's not that you're a bull there's
people who out there in the cell and
they
they're pieces of [ __ ]
when i sold cars i actually took offense
to those kind of stuff yeah they're just
pieces of [ __ ] they cheat on their wives
the people come in they sell them a car
they really
they hit on the guy's wife and then two
months later they disappeared we had
this conversation the other day about a
guy named rick visser
the guy i learned from that that he's
he's still at the same [ __ ]
dealership yeah since 19 [ __ ] 87. wow
and now he's making millions over there
they don't do [ __ ] he sells cars by
appointment wow everybody thought they
had them all those years but it's so
weird like uh
let me tell you what i learned selling
that changed my life yeah
well i sold sports information on the
phone sports information
like uh bed stuff like uh 1591
1998 89.90 i worked at a car wash as a
salesman when you came in hey dean
what's going on today listen dean until
i got the special yeah give me 9.95 i'll
take care of everything throw me an
extra two dollars and i'll do harmony
all right yeah and i made a commission
and it was a tremendous living
it was a true maintain song that was a
great living for me yeah if i didn't
become a [ __ ] thief dad partner up
with the cash register [ __ ] i would have
probably still been there yeah because
legitly legitly i was making 300 a day
there yeah that's [ __ ] great working
9th to
yeah come on and that came outside not
even bending over they didn't even
vacuum a car yeah i didn't even vacuum a
car
i stood out there with my jacket on with
my sunglasses
get in the [ __ ] sun i would take them
off to look at people and i go here and
i made it real casual yeah you can buy
the basic for 4.95 what are your [ __ ]
my nah they come in and i go uh
listen to specialty i was always selling
9.95 but 795 no interior
yeah in fact give me 6.95 let's do no
because i still got the same commission
as long as i sold i got the same
commission it didn't matter whether i
sold it for a dollar cost them 25 cents
yeah what do they give a [ __ ] sometimes
i negotiate that way listen what what is
the arm rule three dollars give me
[ __ ] a dollar give me a dollar a
dollar a dollar okay yeah and make sure
you tip the [ __ ] guy
you know that wasn't what made me a
settlement
out there i met these dudes i would meet
these dudes
and they all had nice cars
and they were all from new york long
island new jersey
and they would always go hey how you
doing after two or three times
we become friendly where you from oh
here
pizza this same [ __ ] they were nice
guys they weren't involved in drugs
and i started asking them what do you
guys do
and like we work up the corner at this
[ __ ] place and we give out sports
information it's great job man
these guys are making banks and think
that right wow
and after about a year i bumped into one
of them hey man we've been looking for
you you want to come in for an interview
and i went in i went into the trainee
program and it changed my whole life
it changed my whole life it looked it
changed my whole sales life forever your
style they did they teach you something
brilliant yeah brilliant
this was something that these guys were
basically street thugs that were
intelligent that got a pitch and
made a science behind it right i didn't
do did i like their style
the two guys i worked for were brothers
i really enjoyed them their partner
really bothered me their partner was in
long island or whatever he was a [ __ ]
douchebag right but these two guys i
worked for were sincere i really liked
them
and they just taught me stuff that blew
my mind
that today i use i use in my regular
life and i think back to them my
relationship with these guys
didn't end too good
and it was all a misunder [ __ ]
standing you know right and there's a
guy from that group that helped me out a
lot that i wish i could hunt them down
and
repay them some of the money at home
but it was just a weird time in my life
but
these guys broke sales down to me deemed
right down to a [ __ ] science wow i
was maybe 30 years old and they
reprogrammed me
until today as lee lee when i tell you
to go pick up the 15 grand
well he looks at me with his mouth open
that's what these guys taught me
they taught me like you know uh
dean what is the florida improv paying
you a week 1200.
grab the [ __ ] phone
you know
and also this guy calls and knows and
he's getting you three thousand dollars
and you're like what the [ __ ] was that
wow did i leave 1800 on the table or is
this guy a good [ __ ] salesman yeah
do you know what i'm saying how how were
they
how are their uh tactics different like
it was a science yeah
it was a science and you had to be a
[ __ ]
knowing what i know now today
i could disappear
and do a hundred grand a year probably
wow my friend danny b who's called into
the show
he probably does 200 grand 300 grand 400
grand a year probably doing this wow but
he works
selling sports tips betting bit talking
to people getting information paying for
information yeah getting information
what is information joey information is
little [ __ ] things okay
there was a fight i watched recently
and i liked the way the turnout ended i
didn't complain about it
but
somebody told me recently that the guy
lost that bad
because he on the wake cup
he passed out twice wow one time he
passed out for so long to actually
thought about calling an ambulance wow
that's not good when you're fighting no
if you know that information how much
did you pay for that yeah you pay 5 000
but now you got to find somebody so you
can make 50 000 right right that's the
secret now are there people scamming out
there yeah there's people who are
running game and running these poor
degenerate gamblers down
listen the degenerate gambler and the
[ __ ] i was doing for 27 years snorting
coke yeah has no differences at all no
you're just robbing stealing clawing to
[ __ ]
uh get your adrenaline [ __ ] going
that's all it is it's two different
[ __ ] eyes yeah but the same cat you
know what i'm saying that's the same
magician yeah but two different tricks
so it's amazing how he attacked him he
had a tv show that came on friday night
like hey on like public access four guys
me you lisa yet
and we get theo van in here yeah and
theovan and you and me and lisa
just argue
and talk about this weekend in sports
well last week and what did you make
last weekend dean delray seven grand
last week while you were at home jerking
off with your baby and your wife you
know what i worked down here
college football i write down 225 000
okay and that was net and i put in six
power moves
and i went six for seven you know yeah i
bet every team for two thousand dollars
scientifically but there was one bet i
made for all the money i made the day
before you just have a spiel yep and
lisa has to jew and he listen [ __ ] you
last weekend i made 300 000 where the
[ __ ] were you [ __ ] on one power
play i had the atlanta falcons getting
four points and i sit on there and all
of a sudden we just sit there and you
give out your 800 number yeah dean del
rey is here he went four for four call
me now let me give you the same topics i
have people are fired up i'll give you
guys [ __ ] so now here you go you call
up you're the kiss of death you can't
pick a winner it's your mom's birthday
next week you told you take it to aruba
you still haven't purchased the ticket
the last time you checked it's three g's
your mother's dying of cancer the
chemo's killing her you told her you had
the money and all of a sudden
you're down two g's you got
a 1200 in the bank
and you got 700 on the atm card and you
got a card that's wide open with 50 000
cash that you have to come up with a
code to [ __ ] snap well guess what
just give us the card we'll get the code
yeah yeah take that card to the mirage
in vegas they'll have the code like that
for you within minutes don't have that
[ __ ] code
man i know i'm so glad i was never a
gambler that [ __ ] will take you that's
why women are going nuts with gambling
now there's
casinos and whatnot so now you call me
and go hey
how you doing i just saw your ad on tv
yeah and it says you if you i call in
right now you'll give me the free pick
all right where'd you bet last week dean
what's your name dean dean how are you
doing joey i'm not one of the advisors
i'm just going to talk to you about
something what did you bet last week
dean i lost 300
that's what i lost i only bet 10 dollars
a game you're [ __ ] yeah yeah and all
of a sudden they give you they you gave
me your number
that's the end of your phone
don't ever think you're gonna recover
that phone ever again yeah these are
real old-school jews yeah they will call
you every minute of the [ __ ] day
in the middle of whatever the [ __ ] yeah
hey you haven't called in man you know
it looks like 49ers you know no so
you're like okay so why am i giving you
this number because the guy's gonna call
you back with your free pick why can't
you give it to me because i don't
[ __ ] know it just give me the goddamn
number you're down money you want to win
some money right yeah give me the
[ __ ] number three two three four four
four four four four four all right call
me back that's it you just signed your
death warrant you might as well gave us
your social security number that is like
that phone number is death yeah debt
especially today i can't even imagine
what they could do for you with the
google and the emails and the facebooks
yeah i will [ __ ] your world up until you
call me back you understand me wow every
time you look at your facebook and be a
message with me with a big dick even if
you block me i'll have 18 different
accounts
i'm paying a guy 500 a week just to open
up fake accounts coming at you with dick
pics yeah you're gonna have to take care
you're gonna have to get rid of your
facebook page with your 1200 pictures
that you with led zeppelin smoking dope
with ricky rachman at the [ __ ] viper
room
you have to get rid of all those
pictures [ __ ] now you're going to hold
on to dear lord so you better answer me
the [ __ ] back eventually that's how it
works once you give me your phone number
in that business because this is what
happens i call you back how you doing
dean hey great
listen can i get my free pick dean
listen up for a second the guy i work
for is lisa you ever hear lisa no you
haven't he's a real estate mogul
this guy made his money in the 80s
selling oil
and he took it over to arab villa and he
came back with [ __ ] billions now he's
bored and he's gambling so he's bought a
piece of these [ __ ] this society
these refs
coaches trainers he's on the inside he's
on the inside he tells you what's going
on all right for example last night we
made what lenny what'd we make last
night
eighty-two thousand boss eighty-two
thousand dollars on one [ __ ] move
what did you make last night obviously
you didn't make that you're calling me
because you're a [ __ ] loser okay dean
delray do me a favor
tonight i got a [ __ ] pick that's
going to make your [ __ ] eyeballs pop
up wouldn't what's delray what
nationality's dull right what is that
what is that what are you irish what are
you yeah man
i'm i'm uh dutch dutch okay listen dutch
boy [ __ ] paint
i'm gonna make you so much [ __ ] money
tonight you're gonna hire 12 of those
little white [ __ ] to paint your
[ __ ] house all right
now do me a favor dean grab your card
we're going to start off with 300 i'm
going to start you off at 300 till you
make 3 000. okay don't bug me after that
because after that i'll charge you a
little more
all right grab your card how do you want
to pay me dean oh it's just my card it's
fine oh great boom i got a [ __ ] great
bling you got to put resistance on me
yeah you gotta [ __ ] you know go i
don't know let me think about it and
call you back yeah are you sure i'm
gonna win i told my mother i was taking
a [ __ ] aruba next weekend
yeah and i just dig into you and i will
call you
now even after i call you and get you to
pay me the 300 no matter what happens
even if we lose a thousand i go into you
like it's like nothing happened yeah
listen
you were supposed to lose that thousand
so you can get this next yeah yeah yeah
yeah and i mean they milk you to death
so now once you tell me to go [ __ ]
myself i don't call you i just give this
to a pig a room next to me
the guys because we have 18 guys working
for a
lisa construction company yeah but 16 of
them are superstar sports and the other
16 of them are [ __ ] joey diaz
advantage sports yeah so that [ __ ]
lead goes to two other companies and
then once we get finished with it guess
what we do
we give that same number to [ __ ] 20
companies across the country for 50
cents on the dollar wow and on that
information i already got your hammocks
i got your visa card i got your [ __ ]
dinos club
it really is amazing what i learned what
people vulnerable people
will [ __ ] give you that's radical how
[ __ ] bosses are corporations would
have their secretaries wire me money
with their visa cards because they
couldn't have their wives find out from
their corporate accounts jesus just the
[ __ ] craziest [ __ ] you've ever heard
gambling man
gambling is the devil
everything is the devil totally music
drugs drugs yeah everything scientology
everything's the [ __ ] he's the devil lee
what are you thinking about two tacos
christina's right now he is the devil
right now look at him look at poorly
jesus christ at least 600 milligrams was
still tender
will you gamble at all i love gambling
yeah yeah you gotta watch what are you
into i like everything blackjack
he uses the same story against me and i
still i still stand that i'm right i
always started when he gave me money he
stayed to me very nice thank you
and then i started winning he walked
away don't walk away when someone's when
when someone's winning you do the same
thing i want you to be a man's man i
want you to be your own man
you're a rabbit's foot [ __ ] fellas
your [ __ ] rabbit's [ __ ] sick
you just got [ __ ] you gotta stay there
who told you to move oh yeah that's what
i would say who told you you know that's
pretty interesting that uh you're
attacking comedy like you listen man
it's all of
all this [ __ ] man it's just a
a journey it is it's just really a
journey
and if you're looking to make money get
out of it now if you're looking to
become a millionaire be on the cover of
something get out of bed now
if you're just looking to
do your journey and pay for your bills
and sustain yourself yeah how happy are
you figure out how to get insurance
you know i mean we came in a time where
we're very fortunate people in americans
like it's very hard for them to get any
[ __ ] type of insurance totally i got
that sag insurance and i remember when i
got on like
why this deep pain he has people keep
sending me letters
yeah you know like i thought it was
inconvenience i didn't need insurance
all right so i was never gonna need
insurance this was [ __ ]
[ __ ] weak people [ __ ] that insurance
does good now that [ __ ] is god
so it's just uh
i tell you joey it's it's so funny
because i'm coming up
in about three weeks will be seven years
it's gone by
so [ __ ] the sobriety part of it
just i'm saying doing comedy oh okay
yeah i've been doing comedy seven years
and three weeks here
uh told uh what was it it was uh
december six is the first time i went on
stage so like a month away
and i think about how fast seven years
have gone by
and how much fun i've had
and all these new friends i have you
know what i mean well you've impressed a
lot of comedians with your heart
and you're very kind and you're very
sweet you're not like these [ __ ]
egotistical guys that you already saw a
taste of life when you got involved with
tommy yeah yeah so you've been doing
comedy seven years right now at this
point yeah seven years
wow
i didn't know dick i thought i was the
king
i had booked the pilot for cbs yeah taco
bell commercial
and i had a role in baseball
and i thought i had the answer and i had
this pilot at cbs
and i thought the pilot they blew smoke
up everybody's ass it was the guy who
got the money they paid him 3 million to
direct the [ __ ]
series why would they pay somebody if
they're not going to pick up the [ __ ]
show yeah cbs didn't pick it up
so but i was at the store dying deandari
in 98 i was at the store getting a
beaten
from don herrera um
aj jamal aj jamal that was his [ __ ]
name wow aj jamal was a black kid that
was uh very clean
with dreadlocks yeah and he went up
there and they fell in love with him so
much king kong couldn't [ __ ] follow
him wow
it was weird and then she would give me
two spots on the weekends one in the
[ __ ] main room following dom herrera
to die yeah and then they'll have to
creep over and follow aj jamal in the
original room just two
girls two funerals for the same fat [ __ ]
at that point i'd have the coke already
waiting for me so i could just grow in
the bathroom cry and snort
but right after the [ __ ] original
room seven years in
seven years and i was struggling man
dying i'm in my sign with the manager
and he sent me to jacksonville florida
headline yeah and between you and i
it was an ego
i looked down on him i looked down at
this club when i walked in there for
some reason or another
i just said uh ah you know i'm not into
this club yeah and i walked in and i
looked at the schedule and i go holy
[ __ ] there's a real club oh yeah you saw
people who yeah
people out of l.a people have been in
movies like holy [ __ ]
and i went up there and i started dying
oh no on the 35 minute mark oh because i
lose 15 minutes with the regional [ __ ]
yeah right oh yeah yeah you're right i
got you yeah it was 15 minutes you've
been down at the grove i was at the
grove boom done all that material's gone
the 170 yeah the armenians yeah
the furniture stores in north hollywood
i was just talking to ari about that you
know you lose all that [ __ ]
you know so right away you have 35
minutes and here you are in this [ __ ]
city you're trying to look good for this
[ __ ]
booker who's gonna be there thursday
night by the way
that he's going away and you're up there
after 35 minute mark and you're starting
to improvise yeah you're improvising
like so what do you guys do for a living
it's a [ __ ] slow debt oh so nobody
could [ __ ] tell me nothing about
comedy yeah the sun i got here when
90s
what are we 216 right now yeah coming to
an end i gotta look at this poor bastard
i got here
in 207 97
and that first year i signed with a
manager i booked the pilot for cbs
i started going on the road a little bit
as an mc i was on the road right but i
had a manager who was a booker
at creative entertainment of north
carolina
there's something else now they booked
charlotte now have you been to charlotte
no uh i was in uh durham north carolina
with burr a couple weeks ago that's a
theater though yeah you know this is a
club in charlotte gotcha it's a great
[ __ ] club it's not there forever
still there still there they run it but
they have the room with the bermuda so
they they booked jamaica if you want to
go to jamaica and do comedy they book it
that's 300 a week 300 a week and they
fly you down
all right you're there for two weeks you
bring your family
but you're getting three hundred a week
oh man i mean mc gets like twenty two
fifty or twenty two
and you can't curse you can't do nothing
like that because they'll whisk you
right off the [ __ ] island oh yeah
that's next the weirdest thing
yeah
comedy is you know it's it's uh
i i was talking to uh a friend of mine
on a car ride up by headlines friday
night fresno
and
you know you spend all these years doing
the feature spot of 20
and 20 is just crushing and
and
you got to watch out because you can get
a little [ __ ] delusional like man i'm
[ __ ] this this i'm getting good here
but that's nothing
it's the hour of going out and
headlining and that's a whole different
flavor
whole different animal
what you do is you book yourself in seat
rooms yeah you get a list of [ __ ]
serums
and you tell them listen i'll take you
what you do and you do this for yourself
it's not for the dog you're gonna break
even right you're gonna because you're
gonna give you 800 for the week
okay and that's all they do
sorry yeah if jesus came in here we do
800 for the week we know our audience we
do 10 tickets on saturdays and 12 50 on
sunday you know what i'm saying like yep
there's towns like that like it's a sea
room it's just the what are you gonna do
nobody goes there anymore but you're
gonna go there you're gonna go there
from scratch and
do that once a month but train yourself
to do 70
70 even if you're lullaby in them oh
jesus yeah even if they're [ __ ]
falling asleep in front of you
you're getting that ice in the blood
even if they heckle you and go when is
this gonna end yeah yeah all that [ __ ]
yeah
that's where you really cut your thief
yeah because that's how i cut my teeth
to people yelling hey man what the [ __ ]
you know who echoed me one time
rogan yeah i was bombing so bad at the
store
rogan heckled me in the very beginning
wow i didn't talk to him for like a
month but i go he got every right the
heck what did he say i'm in the back
then i'm throwing these [ __ ] [ __ ]
curveballs that i think are brilliant
yeah at the store i got 11 o'clock spot
the room is filled yeah filled people
coming in to watch
and i'm on stage dying
and after eight minutes i go boy
this is killing me and also rogue was in
the back he goes it's [ __ ] killing me
oh
and the room started laughing and after
that there wasn't one bit of [ __ ]
there was not a [ __ ]
line of funniness after that wow
oh man you're just like oh my god i was
embarrassed oh
you know i mean you you just bombed man
yeah i just bombed for the first special
the first show i thought i bombed oh on
the first uh last week at the shoot oh i
couldn't keep it together really yeah
yeah i started doing old jokes and back
peddling then i had a little and then
once you lose the war
you just tap out you hope that the
second show
goes a lot better and you go back to
technique and you go back to what you've
learned and what you're strong with and
that's exactly how it worked out what
happened do you think you took the first
show lightly like i got this no let me
tell you what i did yeah no humanity
sometimes man i go on stage and i want
to be somebody else
i want to appear to be like seinfeld
yeah but that don't work for me yeah i
got to be able to [ __ ] you all you
always have to be who the [ __ ] you are
in your life
leave was i not me in the second show it
was a and everyone thought everyone was
like oh good joke good show but yeah the
second show was amazing it was just
something that it's 25 years yeah that's
it this is what we do yep i was sitting
there for three hours doing
and i heard willie and willie going you
know what joe you're a good storyteller
and i said you know what i came out
there [ __ ] throwing heat
let me do something different for the
second shot went out and said man say a
story and i just told the story who the
[ __ ] knows what the [ __ ] the story was
wow and then from there i took it into
the set and now you show humanity they
know what time it is yeah you know it
was just sometimes in here that's why i
didn't like doing blow all those years
that's what frustrated me the most about
snorting cocaine and trying to do
stand-up comedy that no matter how good
the material was while i was doing blow
that [ __ ] fury
would never unleash yeah that fury at
the comedy store that i unleash
sometimes yeah i know it's only 18
minutes and if i have a heart attack
it's not gonna be yeah i only got six
minutes to walk out so i have i could
die on the [ __ ] part yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know i go strong
at the club i know i got an hour up
there you know you get all fired i've
been with you man the face gets purple
and [ __ ]
yeah so you [ __ ] go off you know
you're really feeling this joke right
now yeah you're really feeling the story
so
at the store you go up there you got to
give it everything the [ __ ] you got
something i always do
i don't take that place light at all no
no and you're gonna bomb everybody
[ __ ] bombs man no matter what you do
you bomb if you're a contractor one day
i'm gonna come in and go dean today i
gotta do a bunch of [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] the
secretary today can i leave you here
alone yeah sure enough there's gonna be
two things you're gonna [ __ ] up is he
he's gonna be like i know i should have
left you alone yeah and you're gonna
feel shitty about it but you know what
you're gonna learn a lesson and he's
gonna and he's gonna bust your balls all
the time yeah you know about it lee how
you feeling over there you're all right
you're seeing things
i gotta go i'm not i'm off to the store
very nice i i i mean
wait hold on
i'm not saying i'm seeing like
almost things yet
almost things yet what kind of things
you're seeing [ __ ] i love it you
guys i'm seeing almost things what a
shame we had john tonight we didn't even
talk about music it's all right last
time we played videos we [ __ ] play
videos we get people [ __ ] hot all
right though because sometimes uh
you know i mean it's just organic that's
why i like to come on here it's wherever
it goes it goes seven years i am so
proud of you thank you man uh took three
or four reasons number one
you're a sweetheart of a guy
you're never showing up for a handout
you always do the work you don't mind
doing the work listen i'll ride a
bicycle to the gig if i can open up for
you
you're very you want to do this you're
at an age that a lot of people don't
think of doing dick yeah yeah you're in
a lot of people go let me just go to the
subway and steam it out i get social 55
we're both at that age where we could
have tapped out a while ago still i
don't want to tap out ever i never went
to get on government
right my mom didn't come here to [ __ ]
put me on free fl i'd rather rob you
before i go get free [ __ ]
i just worked all my life you know what
i mean i can't imagine not working you
know and like comedy is just like well
listen you didn't also start this when
you were 23 yeah which meant that you
were at the bar there was a hangar and
i'll go back with
red band and drink though eight in the
morning yeah this is business yeah yeah
this at one point and and you whatever
you're doing in your life uh
you party and you you cut corners and
you get away with little things but to
see the big picture any career
in any [ __ ] career whether it's real
estate it's when you put your full focus
yeah you know and you could do
the math yourself you're not ignorant
look at the time when you've been sober
and you've done your work and look at
the time my work is [ __ ] tremendous i
mean i always had a great work that work
ethic but no matter what the the 90 on
my mind was how i was going to score
that next rock that night yeah exactly
that was always a little bit more
important than me
once i scored the rock then i could be
funny jack oh yeah
i don't have that enigma in front of me
anymore i don't have to wake up to that
i wake up to being funny or writing this
today or
so i talk seven years you're doing great
things you're fearless
yeah i've never heard you complain
you're fearless which
listen any [ __ ] career is the number
one thing
that's it plain and simple fearless i'll
[ __ ] go down there on sunday
that's why i know there's a lot of shell
i don't even volunteer for no more
because yeah
yeah yeah yeah so no man keep doing what
the [ __ ] you're doing you're out there
thank you man you play your music you
ride your motorcycle dean uh
you're making a living you know you're
putting away a couple dollars here and
there when you can
you catch your breathing what else you
want like that's it man i just did
comedy for a [ __ ]
20 days in new york i just look at that
like wow stay in the apartment on the
lower east side yeah right you woke up
to bagels nobody asked you for a 20
billion you got more you know you don't
give a [ __ ] are you he's great ari's
family he's not going to say let's just
clean the place and don't leave no
rubbers or whatever
he's so great he leaves your weed
there's food in the refrigerator yeah
yeah ari's [ __ ] family so you know
what when you have these advantages you
have to take advantage of these [ __ ]
advantages go to new york and even hey
listen who the [ __ ] am i
to tell you not to experience new york
in december no man i'm going oh well
it's free [ __ ] i'll take the animal
this size you'll call me and go joey
jesus [ __ ] christ when that wind goes
in that subway station
i had that in august i was there in this
[ __ ] 4 million degrees there was an
incinerator man just down in the subway
showing up at shows your pants are just
wet no no no there's no way to live
though listen i'm gonna tell you a true
story yeah
there were two concerts that i walked
out of there
and it was a horror show but the main
concert
was ac dc
at
the palladium august 2nd
1980 or 81 the second night they started
they always opened that tour to
philadelphia and they went to palladium
in new york
i kid you not bro i had sweat down to my
knees on my jeans
the the
the belt buckle the belt loop there yeah
yeah that inch around your waist
was covered with sweat
the t-shirt i had on the people next to
me it just smelled like shoes at the
palladium it's brutal brutal that
[ __ ] humidity as you believe the
cocaine would melt oh oh oh it's just
gone and the seal a meal remember those
ceiling meals it'd just be gone you
would cut the cocaine lee and moving the
whole thing would move with the razor
blades it's gone and you go you know
what we're done we got to snort it
before if not we lose it ghost kills he
[ __ ] loses it i'm going to do some
shout outs if i got a gun i got to go go
do your thing thank you so much
this [ __ ] love you guys thank
you for coming on a sunday night edition
oh god i'm the [ __ ] church of what's
happening now church sorry we didn't
really cover a lot of music tonight
next month we'll bring rain and we'll
[ __ ]
do uh get down on that blind melody you
know i'm gonna listen to that blind
melody please i didn't like him i really
please do check out the record soup and
the song galaxy it's incredible i love
you [ __ ] you know your way out
there's a door out there yeah you know
how to slide up thank you we'll talk
during the week
thomas
hannington
sean
thomas
jordan hutchinson
alex carter let me do this again because
there was a lot of movement here
thomas hannington sean thomas
jordan hutchinson alex carter
stephen carrillego
johnny papalia
phillip rusty buselly
and jason seaguars who the [ __ ] is
better than you on a monday morning you
understand me at least you're getting
thought about
somebody's thinking about you [ __ ]
what's going on lee how you feeling
i am feeling good um well you gonna talk
to me like that tell me you know what
i'm feeling like a [ __ ] animal in
heat
a freak without warning
i'm trying to figure out how i feel
um
it's not really kicking it's kicking in
but nothing really crazy yet i don't
know a piece i don't want you to say i
gave you a [ __ ] fugazi piece
take a chance columbus did what are you
gonna do you got nothing to do tomorrow
what are you gonna do
other than live uh what are you gonna do
where you gonna go
no you got nothing to do tomorrow take a
chance columbus did lose you oh [ __ ]
isn't you no it's not me that's you [ __ ]
nut
who's pet texting and [ __ ] look at you
that's mama she's watching oh [ __ ]
she's watching the show she knows you're
[ __ ] hiding [ __ ] now
you didn't save her star she's got you
on the eyeball of debt
that time you brought her into your
office she bugged the office do you see
him saying
what's up lee give me those things will
you
look at you having a little heart attack
over there you got anxiety i love it
it's a typical sunday night here at the
church office
i'm happy you [ __ ] typed in on
a monday morning uh
great week coming up halloween is [ __ ]
next weekend
everybody's
i'm gonna be in las vegas friday night
and saturday night at the south point
with my man uh steve
simone and i guess larry now since he's
unemployed or something
something what happened to my man larry
so we're gonna have to chip in and get
him a [ __ ] car he's gonna be the uber
driver of the [ __ ] year my brother
larry you know what i'm saying what do
you think about that i love it he said
yeah yeah he needs a new car to do uber
so yeah we're gonna have to chip in and
get him a [ __ ]
nice corvette or something so they could
do uber get him a special
larry [ __ ] poken lair
uber car and [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying how you feeling over that lee
what do you got planned for this week
[ __ ]
everything's out the window now i went
back to jiu jitsu i'm very happy i went
sadly and today
my breathing is off but [ __ ] it i'm
going to keep going
since my back i didn't want to overdo it
i went a little bit both days just to
really tomorrow i go to the class
i'll probably do the drills like i did
today and get thrown up in the air and
[ __ ] like that and just get loose and uh
it's great to be back
i took that week off guys and i got to
tell you something man i only did two
podcasts and i went to that meeting
and i spent time with my family i didn't
even open up
a comedy notebook did you know that i'm
not gonna open up a comedy notebook till
tomorrow morning
how long has it been since you've taken
that long off
uh last december
i took a two-week layoff off
after the new year's show because i
couldn't do it i couldn't say those
jokes anymore i was [ __ ] dying inside
so i went up there april and chad
remember we went to the year started at
[ __ ] flappers
i warmed up by flappers on a tuesday
night and [ __ ] ripped it up nicely
you know i hadn't been on stage and
sometimes it's good to take a little
breather
sometimes you make good strides i had a
good day i had a way better day at jiu
jitsu than i thought i was gonna have
i did one thing that was impressive at
least for me i lasted in one thing
i took my [ __ ] little protein water
and i went home you know me dog i don't
[ __ ] around dog your cardio survives my
cardio is
that one week remember that [ __ ]
before i shot that special like a week
before the special
i started smoking cigarettes like i
would smoke [ __ ] little uh those
ultralight
disgusting they were disgusting guys but
for some reason i wanted to get
everything sharp i wanted not to forget
there's something in my head like i told
you when i used to go to auditions the
[ __ ] character for me started when i
went in the show so when i did the
special i was gonna go back to chicago i
don't know i wanted to feel [ __ ]
dirty without feeling dirty
so i bought a pack of marlboro ultra
lights one night and they are the most
disgusting
[ __ ] things i came to a conclusion
last week
that the worst things on this listen
every once in a while you want me to lie
to you and tell you if i'm on a [ __ ]
flight
and i don't have a star
that i won't get a [ __ ] uh doers and
ginger ale draw me the lighting and tell
you i'm not a doers and ginger ale guy
do you want me to lie to you and tell
you that i'm not a [ __ ] sometimes
i'll just drink an irish cream iris
bailey's on the rocks that's it yeah
that's why i'm not gonna lie to nobody
last week in chicago i had a frangelico
or whatever the [ __ ] it was yeah
angelico frangelico with irish cream
with some ice cubes and a little cream
in there and i know that i like all that
type of [ __ ] i don't want to get
hammered but you know what whenever i
drink alcohol whether it's one shot or
two shot on the plane when i get home
and i drink water and stuff like that
the next morning i feel okay i don't
feel the alcohol whatever i'm deciding
to do and i'm gonna walk that day or run
or do kettlebells i feel okay i gotta
tell you something you smoke [ __ ]
cigarettes
the next day you feel like [ __ ] death
you really do
and i came back that night i threw him
in the thing and i didn't [ __ ] smoke
another cigarette and that was it
i just wanted it before the special to
calm me down when i was there i didn't
want to do alcohol and i didn't want to
have 22 stars in my [ __ ] system
between the reefer and the [ __ ]
cigarettes that caught me to [ __ ] down
cigarettes calm down
i've never smoked something in my world
something for some reason made me pull
him up and you know what what lee the
result was great it was my result and
what did i do i threw the [ __ ]
cigarettes out that night and that was a
week ago that was eight days ago no
[ __ ] problem nobody got their
feelings hurt
my lungs a tip tap to magoo i did the
stand master that [ __ ] day at the
hotel so i'm good man
it's amazing that you can go in and out
of that uh addiction so easily there's
no addiction there's no addiction it's
[ __ ]
disgusting i want you to smoke one time
in your life whether it's a cigar smoked
cigars they're the most disgusting thing
in the world
i love these people who smoke a cigar
and i want to ask them pull them in the
corner and go tell me the truth
you really like smoking this [ __ ] you
really like that taste in your [ __ ]
mouth and you breathe on people i gotta
smell that [ __ ]
who's breathing on people well people
who smoke cigars breathe on you [ __ ]
they want to come up close and talk to
you like the johnny mafia and they want
to hit you with that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] cigar death breath smell in your
face like i need that [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out of here
let me tell you something uh
it's the holiday season
and uh you know we got a great podcast
man and we have a select
group and uh i have a great couple
agents and they contact me every like 30
days and they give me a list of people
that uh they're marketing for now and
they say to me you know joey look at
this and
the people i'll say you know what yeah i
like that something to send me a case of
that or
do this and do that and eventually we
all me and lisa down you know
i don't want to ever bring something on
here to you people that you're gonna
look at me and go join what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] number one you're unique
you don't walk like everybody you don't
talk like everybody you don't sleep like
everybody so why is your mattress one
size fits all why
because a custom mattress will cost you
five to ten thousand dollars
until now
introducing ready for this the helix
sleep
where you can buy matches online
customized for you for hundreds of
dollars instead of thousands all right
you go to helixsleep.com answer simple
questions based on four key preferences
and the result will be a custom sleep
profile
used to build you the most comfortable
mattress you'll ever sleep on you dig
your mattress will arrive at your door
in about a week and shipping is 100 free
all right and for the couples helix
customizes each side
of the mattress all right healer's
customers report a 30 improvement and
overall sleep quality you got a hundred
nights to try it out and if you don't
love it they pick it up for free and
give you 100 refund no questions asked
that's why everyone from gq magazine to
forbes are all talking about the healing
sleep do me a favor right now go to
helixsleep.com
joey and you get dollars off your entire
order right that's helixsleep.com
joey
helixsleep.com
joey i'm gonna give you fifty dollars
off your order all right listen if you
don't sleep you can't go out there and
sling dick that's the bottom [ __ ]
line all right believe me if you want if
you think you can sleep four hours a
night on the couch and be tiptoe magoo
the next day it's not gonna work it only
works for a little while give helix
sleep a try right now
listen i just got this in the mail
i tried the blueberry one you know
i'm not an expert on waters i do know
what i like and i do know what i don't
like
i don't like drinking the water when it
tastes overwhelming
and i don't like drinking the water
where the taste is too sweet where it's
too not you know you can't taste it it's
not natural it's not natural then
there's that one flavor i just tried
this today the blueberry i think it's
the blueberry
it was
delicious do you understand me you know
you should drink eight glasses of water
a day
but who really does
coffee soda energy drinks why don't you
just drink more water cause it's bland
and you want something that tastes good
here's the solution
drink hit water instead listen i'm like
you guys sometimes i'm drinking water i
feel like a prisoner i don't like water
sometimes but if you want to drink
something that's healthy and at the same
time get your fix
this is it my friend
you know you should drink eight glasses
of water a day but again hemp water was
started by cara golden a few years ago
as to after having a fourth child she
was overweight
she had terrible acne and felt awful she
was drinking 10 diet sodas a day you
know what that sounds like me instead of
drinking water because water was boring
what other what other options did she
have
juice is full of calories and there's no
calorie drinks in garbage
that's why she started hitting water
hint water is pure water infused with a
taste of fresh fruit fruit
hemp water drinking water isn't boring
they have flavors to suit your palate
watermelon peach
mango grapefruit and many more no sugars
no chemicals just great tasting
all-natural
fruit flavored water both health and
self magazines have name hint water for
the best flavored water and they know
how important drinking plenty of water
is to your health you know what
let's open up one right now
in fact that's what i had before
me i'm thinking blueberry watermelon
let's taste this together it's chilled
you know what guys
this is delicious hint is pure water
infused with fresh fruit
no sugar no chemicals just great tasting
all natural fruit flavored water both
health and self magazines have named him
water the best flavored water and they
know how important drinking water is
every day do me a favor right now okay i
just drank some watermelon infused with
it's water infused with watermelon and
the other
natural
flavors from non-gmo
plants there you go i can't see with
these glasses guys i'm so sorry zero
calories unsweetened
best enjoyed chilled
born in san francisco i love this stuff
all right and right now get a single
variety pack shipped directly to your
door including three bottles of each of
his most popular flavors pineapple
watermelon crisp apple and blackberry
see i did have the blackberry i'm
hallucinating here normally twenty four
dollars i'll tell you what we're gonna
do for only 15 at drink hint.com
church again normally 24 hours we're
going to get it for fifteen dollars at
drink hint dot com slash church that's
drink hint
h i n t
dot com slash church drink hint dot com
slash church give it a try it's
delicious the watermelon was good and
the blackberry was good that's how we're
rolling here lee what are you looking at
you're all confused over there
as usual you guys been known you've been
following me on the church here for how
long you know i love you in all my heart
i appreciate you guys all right
uh
a couple weeks ago we got this thing uh
uh
did you hook it up yet to see so oh yeah
my wife hooked it up to the roku my wife
loves it she watches the sad night lives
on there the old saturday night lives i
came in the other night i gotta tell you
as much as sometimes i don't like life
saying that live i was kind of laughing
and she told me
this was uh
part of
see
see-saw and i'm like really i didn't
know this
i did not even know this [ __ ] okay yeah
and i got see so for the doug stanhope
special a couple weeks ago is that what
you got it for that's what i got it for
a couple weeks ago and they have a
couple they have some uh aboriginal
programming from jonah ray i believe and
they have a lot of great original
programming and it's just they're just
gonna keep having
more and more it's uh it's a lot of
really cool and they have hours of
specials
well all i know is one thing i'm very
happy that my special's going to air on
there
december 8th on ceso now what's the best
thing you've bought for 3.99
i bought ciso ciso has nearly endless
supply of top shelf comedy literally
months of worth of exclusive originals
face melting stand up and next day late
night and great catalog of classics cso
is the place for comedy
they won't tell you how amazing they are
but we will cezo is amazing it's comedy
for comedy nerds by comedy lyrics like i
said the other night we were watching
sinai live it was hilarious i mean
you know what i didn't when i signed
that live was coming out i wasn't really
[ __ ] into it because i was getting
high and [ __ ] like this
but it was tremendous ceso
spelt s-e-e-s-o
is the new ad-free streaming service
bringing you hilarious original series
hand-picked classics weeks of stand-up
specials and more
bringable comedy anytime anywhere see so
every episode of snl including new
episodes the day after the air the
tonight show starring jimmy fallon
seth meyers the day after and they even
have classics like dirty rock parks and
rex and saved by the bell even british
comedies like the original office where
ricky gervais the entire monthly python
catalog
the id crowd and the steve coogan as
alan partridge discover the next big
names in comedy and watch the icons
before they make it big like louis ck
when he had hair hannibal barris chelsea
peretti amy schumer bo burnham and
yours truly uncle [ __ ] joey diaz on
december 8 [ __ ] so if you're serious
about comedy
gotta give try the seesaw all right
streaming online
anywhere any place
virtually
unbelievable ciso is ad-free and it's
3.99 per month
that's less you paid for the lat atte
artesian cold brewed coffee you're
holding right now like a half a
fruitcake and right now my listeners can
try ceso for two months when you use
promo code joey at checkout okay again
for you guys that are [ __ ] deaf my
listeners can get cso for free for two
months when you use promo code joey at
checkout and guess what that gets you
even if you get it today which is what
october 25th
that means november 25th that means
december 25th that means you get to
watch uncle joey's special for [ __ ]
free [ __ ] so do me a favor go to
cso.com
right now
cso.com right now to sign up for two
months free with promo code joey j-o-e-y
at the checkout that cso.com
promo code joey that means you get to
see my special for free and i know
you're gonna watch it because you know i
love you and you love me and we love
everybody else all right so one more
time go check out cso.com
joey
go to helixsleep.com
joey and i'll tell you what this [ __ ]
hit water is not too bad lee i got to
give you one
you know what man
it's nice and light so do me a favor
right now all right this is the real
deal holy feel
go to drink no go to hint dot com slash
church all right that's
drink hint dot com slash church
and normally 24 hours i'm going to give
you 15
and drink hint dot com
church listen we'll see you guys
wednesday have a great night stay black
thanks for opening up monday morning was
remember it's your [ __ ] week
write your goals do your 22 push-ups
smoke a bone and get out of the house
sling dick and giving out bubblegum
[ __ ] thank you for listening
so
so
you